U.S President Joe Biden at the cop 27
climate Summit in Egypt Riding High
after a better than expected midterm
elections his message we will hit our
emissions targets and so should everyone
else yes the challenge we Face are great
but our capacity is greater than the
challenge we must never doubt that
so let's Reach Out
take the future in our hands and make
the world we wish to see
that we know we need
a planet preserved for generations to
come
Joe Biden may be here to inject some
momentum into this Summit but there
are CERN amongst the delegates here
because of new and repeated warnings
from scientists that the world is
running out of time to limit global
warming even with the American charm
offensive underway Sky News understands
that behind the scenes there is growing
frustration amongst Western climate
diplomats that some nations are becoming
less not more committed to the global
Target of keeping warming to 1.5 degrees
Celsius do you still genuinely believe
that 1.5 degrees is Within Reach we have
to believe that then we have to do it
that is that we don't really have an
alternative and that's what people have
to get used to the idea that this is a
must and that we have to make the
decisions necessary to honor that goal
[Applause]
now
these activists from across Africa have
plenty to say about honor America is
still the second largest polluter in the
world they say and although today it
announced new support for Egypt to
develop wind power and more money to
help vulnerable African nations adapt to
climate change it is still falling far
short of what is needed this is people
are busy drowning people are busy
starving to death because of the rising
temperatures and people cannot adapt to
starvation while agriculture is being
halted in countries like mine so it's
either now or it's never because we are
hitting a dead end where these climate
change effects cannot be reversed
Joe Biden's brief visit to this Summit
was designed to Galvanize more action
even as America exports record volumes
of oil
another Injustice one of many for those
on the front lines of climate change
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in charmel
Sheikh in Egypt